hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 más romeros sala ya en el
estudio lista para hablar de la
organización mundial de la salud mar que
se ha pronunciado sobre la situación de
la guerra en ucrania le pregunto cuáles
son entonces las novedades del lado de
ms pues la verdad es raúl es que hoy nos
hemos despertado con noticias que son
verdaderamente desalentadoras lado ms
lleva desde el inicio de la guerra
monitoreando cómo avanzan los ataques
sobre la salud en el país y después de
la visita del director de la ms pues
emitieron esta rueda de prensa en la que
escuchamos algunas de sus conclusiones
veamos
almost two and half con casi 200 ataques
contra la salud verificados documentados
por la o ms sobre el terreno ucrania es
testigo de la mayor y más rápida
agresión contra el sistema de salud sus
trabajadores y sus pacientes mientras
hablamos los pocos hospitales que
todavía funcionan están atendiendo
quemaduras heridas de armas y de
metralla muchos siguen sin atención en
sus casas o en las calles con estas
heridas o en the streets beat it is in
your is
realmente son consecuencias devastadoras
como estábamos diciendo porque es que
además de estos 200 ataques contra
instalaciones de la salud hay otros
problemas que hacen que esta atención se
interrumpa por ejemplo estamos hablando
de 400 un 40% perdón de los enfermos de
las casas que hay en ucrania vive con
enfermos crónicos que no están pudiendo
acceder a sus tratamientos y eso también
tiene impactos provoca que por ejemplo
3.000 personas aproximadamente hayan
muerto muertes que son prevenibles por
no poder acceder a esos tratamientos y
muertes que no se han dado en un
contexto de balas o de enfrentamiento
pero que alcanzan casi los tres mil
doscientos civil muertos en esto en este
tipo de conflicto y además estos ataques
como lo estamos reportando cómo afecta
la guerra a la salud de las personas
vamos a recordar vamos a aprovechar para
recordar que el acceso a la salud es un
derecho básico universal y que la guerra
no puede hacer otra cosa que no sea
interrumpir lo realmente de manera
violenta y de manera brutal estamos
hablando que además de estos ataques
contra centros de salud por ejemplo se
restringe la movilidad los profesionales
de la salud o los tratamientos los
medicamentos no pueden llegar a las
personas que lo necesitan por ejemplo
enfermedades como el sida o la
tuberculosis que necesitan
entrenamientos regulares para que dejen
de ser contagiosas si se interrumpen
podríamos ver un aumento descontrolado
de los casos entre la población la
desnutrición también o la falta de
comida de agua ahora mismo 10 millones
de personas necesitan asistencia
alimentaria no nos olvidamos de la salud
mental tampoco esta crisis toca a todo
el mundo de diversas maneras y suele
suceder que en estos contextos pues al
final la salud mental no suele ser una
de las prioridades y sus consecuencias
se ven a largo casa a largo plazo y por
último también la guerra es un campo
abierto para edades infecciosas por por
ejemplo la falta de higiene recordemos
que ucrania ha sufrido dos brotes de
sarampión en los últimos años uno de los
más grandes del mundo fue entre 2017 y
2019 las tasas de vacunación están por
los suelos y una campaña que se había
iniciado para ponerle solución a esto se
interrumpió debido a la guerra entonces
pues eso también puede ser un problema
que veamos o que esté sucediendo y
todavía no tengamos cifras al respecto y
por supuesto también la enfermedad
infecciosa reina el commit 19
precisamente vamos a hablar del coi 19
la situación de la pandemia educar a
animar pues la verdad es que actualmente
seguimos bastante a ciegas porque las
cifras son poco fiables las últimas que
se reportaron en la última semana hasta
el 4 de mayo dicen que hubo 2800 casos y
52 muertes pero no sabemos si estas
cifras son reales o no lo que sí sabemos
por ejemplo son las tasas de vacunación
y no sólo en ucrania sino también en los
países de alrededor que ahora mismo son
los que más refugiados acogen vemos que
ucrania tiene la tasa de vacunación más
baja de toda europa
34% pero es que los países de su
alrededor tampoco están mucho mejores no
son tantos los que alcanzan el 60 por
ejemplo polonia o hungría pero moldavia
uno de los países vecinos donde también
están acogiendo a muchos refugiados solo
alcance el 40 por ciento de tasas de
vacunación entonces pues con todo el
movimiento de gente problemas de higiene
hacinamiento también puede ser que
estemos nos estamos perdiendo no en un
aumento de casos de covite del que no
tenemos reporte y que ha pasado con los
crímenes de guerra en la oms y ha dicho
que los va a investigar o los está
investigando más efectivamente la
organización mundial de la salud ha
dicho que está tratando de recoger
pruebas para demostrar que estos ataques
sobre los centros del personal de salud
son crímenes de guerra recordemos sin
embargo que estos crímenes de guerra
deben ser juzgados en la corte penal
internacional y que es ahí donde se
tienen que demostrar dos cosas uno que
los ataques fueron intencionales que no
fueron accidentes sino que fue un ataque
intencional contra un centro de salud y
dos que no había que no era un objetivo
militar por ejemplo rusia recordemos en
ese ataque al hospital de mariupol del
inicio del conflicto que por unas
imágenes que dieron la vuelta al mundo
dijo que había hecho ese ataque porque
había militar pues integrantes del
batallón a las dos y que por eso era un
objetivo militar todo esto es difícil de
demostrar entonces veremos como se
desarrolla en las instituciones
internacionales marc durante cuánto
tiempo se van a sentir estas
consecuencias de la guerra pues la
verdad raúl es que durante décadas y así
también lo decía la organización mundial
de la salud
el sexo de su conflicto el qashqai down
los efectos de este conflicto se
transmitirán durante generaciones
pedimos a todas las partes un urgente e
inmediato alto al fuego para asegurar el
funcionamiento de corredores
humanitarios ayudar a evacuar residentes
civiles y entregar asistencia
humanitaria y médica para salvar vidas
antibélico existen muchas veces hablamos
de las muertes no contamos las vidas que
se pierden pero qué sucede también con
las que se quedan con todas esas
personas que sobreviven serán años de
problemas de salud mental de
incapacidades de enfermedades crónicas
que aunque la guerra se terminará mañana
raúl se seguirían sintiendo durante años
marc y sin duda obviamente recuerdos y
hechos elementales que los acompañaran
por lo largo de su vida si pierdes toda
tu familia
no se va por supuesto y de hecho es
importante que lo mencionemos para que
las ayudas no sólo sean puntuales no a
veces hay torrentes de ayuda en el
momento de la crisis pero pues ucrania y
sobre todo la población civil de ucrania
va a seguir necesitando asistencia
humanitaria médica durante muchos años
en el futuro así es más muchísimas
gracias como siempre por toda la
información en nuestra sección de salud
pasamos a saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado